Speaker 1: Okay. This is just so funny. It's
sort of like it's not even really adding insult
to injury. It's adding injury to injury. The
day after Trump was found liable for sexual
assault and defamation of Carol and ordered to
pay her $5 million, he went on his CNN town hall
and he made more disparaging comments
about Jean Carroll. And many of us said,
sounds like potentially more defamation. CNBC
reports Trump faces a $10 million defamation claim
by Eugene Carroll after his CNN town hall remarks
he might end up owing more money because of that
nonsense that he said about her. Eugene Carroll
filed court papers seeking very substantial
monetary damages of no less than $10 million from
Trump. In light of recent scathing remarks he made
about her at a CNN town hall. Trump's comments
occurred a day after that jury awarded Carroll
5 million in damages for being sexually abused
and defamed by Trump. She said Trump raped her
in the mid eighties in a dressing room of the
Bergdorf Goodman Department store in Manhattan.
It is continuing. It is continuing, the
lawsuit says. Trump's defamatory statements
post-verdict show the depth of his malice
toward Carroll, since it is hard to imagine
defamatory conduct that could possibly be
more motivated by hatred, ill will or spite.
They go on to say Trump falsely stated
that he did not sexually abuse Carol,
that he has no idea who Carol was and that Carol's
now proven accusation was fake and made up by a
whack job. Trump also insulted Carol's character,
downplayed his sexual abuse of her by asking what
kind of woman meet someone and then within
minutes plays hankie panky in a dressing room.
It's happening again. And you really without
spending too much time on this, you really
have to be a very special kind of person. You
could say delusional, you could say narcissist,
whatever to do a town hall the day after you
lose a defamation suit in court are ordered
to pay 5 million bucks. And then within 24,
26, 28 hours, go on CNN and make more of the
exact kinds of defamatory statements that you
just lost a case over. So at this point, will e
Jean Carroll be able to collect these millions?
I don't actually know the answer to that. Legal
experts who have weighed in say probably, but it
could take a while and now you may be adding even
more on to it. Is Trump doing this because he
genuinely thinks he's never going to pay? Is it
because he doesn't care about the money, which
would be very much unlike Trump? Or is he just
confused about what defamation even is? Let me
know in the comments. I certainly have no idea.